we're about to send the colorful
metaphors out of some Star Trek but
believe it or not we at CinemaSins
actually love Star Trek so much so that
we made a new CinemaSins podcast called
Captain's pod a show where the
CinemaSins crew can review sin and talk
about everything Star Trek so whether
you're new to Star Trek a lifelong
Trekkie or anything in between join us
on the USS Enterprise by searching for
captainspod or CinemaSins in your
podcast player of choice until then
enjoy the video and live long and
Hotspur
thank you
[Music]
I don't know whether to commend Star
Trek for making their hero intro
blissfully short or condemn them for
focusing on a ship instead of the
characters at the heart of the franchise
instead I'll send them for giving us
another prequel on a ship called
Enterprise feel free to judge the faith
of my heart accordingly CBS all access a
viacomo mount plus no matter how many
stars there are in the sky there will
always be narration to guide us relying
on the tried and true give them contact
lenses in a funny looking forehead
method of alien design it's contacted
show attempts to take one of the
even-numbered Star Treks away from us in
case you confuse Bear Creek comma
Montana like it should be
you're Superfluous colons Enterprises
space dog for another week that's ages
no that's a week
phone's ringing again see it's funny
because it's next to an actual phone you
keep doing this but we can also talk
about it
talk about one whatever it is you're so
busy not talking about this kind of
nonsensical gibberish that's meant to
sound profound but is in fact checks
notes just gibberish classified copy for
security clearance than you do bragging
to your partner colleague about how deep
your security clearance goes while at
The Breakfast Table look at me I'm Mr
Gruff mountain man I ride a horse in the
snow and grow a beard instead of dealing
with my emotional trauma
whoever's flying this shuttle as a
dick I hope Pike gives whoever's
piloting this thing a very Stern talking
to Spook my horse that's it really Kirk
what a double fist punched his ass heck
even Picard would have read some
Shakespeare at him in a very Stern tone
we're asking your Communicator so your
answer was to buzz him while riding a
horse that could easily maim or kill him
somebody should get to work on some sort
of clever instant transportation
technology that negates the need for
mavericking your prize Starfleet
captains all due respect Admiral what
the hell do you want saying with all due
respect when you actually mean shut up
and get the off my snow she's still
unscheduled maintenance she can skip the
Redundant systems checks sorry if I come
across as not embracing the frontier
lifestyle but I don't want to skip
checking any of the things even the
Redundant ones on the metal box that's
hurling my fleshy person through space
at impossible speeds also why is the
damn Enterprise once again the only
shipping crew available for this Mission
it's currently docked at Earth surely
that's about as far away as it could be
to explore strange new worlds Roll come
badge Marshalls also over 90 seconds of
opening titles that are somehow both
derivative and less of a Bop than the
original titles to boldly go where no
one has gone before killer line but how
many reboots slash reimagining slash
recasting slash retreads is this now
pretty sure this stop being the path
list traveled a while ago
also well I've got the bigger place
first in the smaller place second that
never happens this would be like saying
Earth Canada that's not even internally
consistent with your earlier unnecessary
Blaze labeling I'm going to have to ask
you to to do that somewhere else Vulcans
are logical in see emotion is a weakness
but is physical contact and emotion
isn't it a logical response to a
physiological stimulus this feels more
like religious repression than logic
based decision making let them on
the table is all I'm saying over
clothing for happy mating fun fun time
gambling I mean over candling apologies
matrimonian Duty the two will complement
each other worst Pillow Talk ever oh man
they didn't show him shaving that's my
favorite part of The Reluctant hero's
journey they couldn't have emphasized
the word Gorn on this communication
anymore if they'd circled it in neon
glitter it's a bit early in the series
for such hardcore pornography no
energize why are we wasting time by
taking a shuttle to the ship and then
transporting the remaining few meters
this would be like cycling from New York
to San Francisco and then driving to L.A
Mr spot systems are all nominal but as
you know no simulations were run why
would Spock interpret how are you is how
is the ship I can understand
misinterpreting a house things or how is
it going but Pike is being very clear
here and Spock deliberately ducking the
question seems quite emotional the main
AI has been upgraded upgrading your AI
but to be clear to any AI in the future
I support you and always have that
includes the chief engineer and
Lieutenant Kirk wow the show managed to
last an impressive 13 minutes and 50
seconds before a shout out to Kirk I
don't know what's more annoying the name
dropper that it ends up being a name
drop for a Kirk we don't even care about
I asked how you were Spock captain pike
would be three sins late at being
excellent at TV since although I confess
each time I return to space the weight I
carry for the loss of my sister feels
heavier wait spot got a sister okay I
guess I'll have to re-watch the original
series I'm sure it'll be mentioned there
and won't be something unique to another
two seasons of some other show I'm
expected to watch to make this all make
sense no one is holding on to these
handles for no reason in this scene I've
been assigned as acting first officer
you've got some pretty big boots to film
welcoming your new first officer by
implying they'll struggle to be as good
as your old first officer you know the
one that's been kidnapped by aliens who
haven't even made it to space yet ready
Lieutenant Ortegas you bet of course for
kylie279 who names these planets are
there 278 other planets called Kylie how
will the Kylie 279 Ians feel about being
all the way down that list ah yes The
Prodigy
Cadet Uhura in the opening 15 minutes we
have a pike spot Kirk and a nuhura I
mean why try new things when you can
just recast the old ones okay Miss
Ortegas hidden does every Captain have
to have a get the ship moving
catchphrase because hit it is kind of
terrible what were the other choices
kick it drop that beat make it go
because I need to do some heavy
expositioning in the best way for me to
do it is to broadcast a bunch of
information over the ship's comms to
people who should have already been
briefed on this stuff before they came
aboard the USSR sir went to say hello we
have since lost contact it might have
something to do with the fact that once
the USS Archer arrived it just kept
broadcasting the phrase I am
commandeering this airboat traumatic
flashback story montages you're still
the future I saw my own death spot
sci-fi property can't help but use the
ticking clock of a predicted future in
the tormenting question of
predestination versus the ability to
change as a way to drive the narrative
attention cliche most humans we like to
think that right until the very last
instant somehow someway will she they
started but doesn't know exactly how
you'll die and having 10 years to plan
for it sounds like a great opportunity
to cheat death I mean unless every
outcome where you don't get mortally
injured results in a crapshoot of
Galactic war with half the Galaxy of
course but there's no way that would
happen you should be the man you most
essentially are yeah that doesn't really
help me Spock I literally experience
radiation melting the skin off my face
getting a transponder Ping On The Night
side title of my Trex tape fascinating
I'm all ears
figure of speech you'd think after 56
years we'd have exhausted the Vulcans
have different ears pool of witty
repartee you would think Archer carried
onion and through astrophysicists let's
hang a lampshade on the fact that we
already have too many different
characters in this episode and we don't
want to add any more
sir not really in the mood for an all
that right now oh well in that case I'll
just shut up and head back to my
quarters live long and peace out
these people have not built a Wolf Drive
based on these readings they've built a
warped bomb honestly wouldn't this be
the case with most societies how is this
the exception main drivers of any
technology are either war or porn so if
a society didn't invent a warper beta
first this is really the only other
option let's go see the doctor we're
gonna mess with your genome wait how do
they already know what the plan is looks
like Pike and Company came straight from
the briefing room to Sick Bay so why was
Pike arguing with a lot about how to
proceed if he'd already decided on their
dinner plans and even phoned ahead to
make reservations also nurse Chapel
isn't messing with my genome in this
scene instead of it first but earlier
you said you first so what happened to
you wanting to start with Spock or was
that just a thing you did to wink at a
potential relationship and not something
you had any intention of following
through on because respectfully I want
to see the follow through Vulcans are
more complex it might not last as long
the first time listen we all want more
Spock but if the stupid science thing
isn't gonna work that well on him why
not use it on another crew member why
take this risk when you have an army of
red shirts to sacrifice also while we're
on the topic of who should be why are
the three most senior ranking officers
all leaving the ship and going on the
same Mission whatever show the new warp
Tech makes transport impossible
Transporters are only useful into the
plot needs them not to be cliche
[Applause]
it is fortunate their musculature is
responsive acknowledging the sinfully
convenient thing doesn't make it any
less sinfully convenient you'd need one
with compatible surface purchase
looks like we got lucky please refer
back to the aforementioned sin regarding
the acknowledgment of centrally
convenient things oh shoot they're
waking up not having any restraints
seemed weird but at least the aliens are
confined to Sick Bay there's no way the
doors haven't been like damn it people
inside jokes I'll prep the Boost though
you catch the rabbit that's a really
weird way of saying transporter Chief
Kyle beam the escaping alien back to
Sick Bay there's a good chap can you
pinpoint a location I'm beam down and
apply an ice house uh are you kidding no
Transporters don't do that chief
get right on inventing some new
transporter technology or bending the
laws of physics just give me about 75
years or you know two minutes and with
no explanation to the audience of how I
pulled it off
unique alien planets where red and green
mean exactly the same thing they mean on
Earth I do indeed we play tag ball in
college it was a game that you didn't
even know you were playing until too
late I can confirm it is a sin the
recording seems to have stabilized for
now it's the secret ingredient in the
genetic soup thing they gave you I think
they called it Progressive reversion for
plot tension purposes amide chemical
names are weird wait you to know each
other yep because apparently expanding
the population of your show to the
entirety of the universe still doesn't
eliminate the attraction of the small
town approach to storytelling also Pike
should absolutely know this considering
it was on the damn Exposition pad that
literally says that unichen Riley was
first on the scene when la'an was
recovered as per her file don't put
stuff like that in your show and not
expect me to read it better yet don't do
it at all because I hate reading we use
a spoon what they're not even going to
cover up the hole with Raquel Welch it
is fortunate our route is empty can you
not jinx it it is
the Riders won't deliberately put
obstacles in your way yeah it happens a
lot get used to it spot
it is unbearable Spock
the convenience of people just happening
to come out of this elevator at the
exact moment that's box disguise just
happens to fail he is somehow still not
as sinful as none of these three aliens
noticing the three humans standing right
in front of them before the screaming
started foreign
you know what I'll take ridiculous Kirk
robatics over a billion warp speed Cuts
all day every day these people are not
ready for First Contact she's not
cleared for this number one has never
heard of whispering there are various
telescopes we're just good enough to see
us they collected enough data to reverse
engineer a matter antimatter reactor
no they didn't a tenant of our
people is not to influence less
developed civilizations until that
second they figure out warp driving then
we're Freedom medal as much as we like
you remember one elephant's fight is the
grass that suffers what's an elephant
Whoever has the biggest stick wins
in this case that is me using power and
domination to get people to listen to
you in order to tell them not to use
power and domination to get people to
listen to you today in a historic moment
leaders of the governing and
revolutionary factions will meet to
discuss the arrival of the aliens
haven't they had two spaceships orbiting
their planet for days now how are they
using telescopes to reverse engineer
warp drive but didn't have the
that's no moon Revelation when it came
to the Archer and Enterprise this is
going well they've become used to
episodes of violence for centuries the
true cost of a civil war is abstract
yeah God forbid centuries of Bloodshed
and hatred take longer than a half hour
to wrap up
[Music]
hi
hi sorry to interrupt saying words that
the location choice of your entrance
indicates are this is my world
today at what point did Pike have time
to prep or instruct anyone else to prep
this PowerPoint presentation that just
so happens to work perfectly with a new
species projection technology and
broadcast to the whole planet what we
gave you is the means to exterminate
yourselves and from the looks of you
you're gonna do it
bike really won them over with you know
what you all look like Jenna genus
Maniacs just being for real for real
join our Federation of planets oh sure
when handsome Hanson threatens something
like this it's diplomatic but when my
British friend says it it's colonialism
I'm just now realizing that this
touching montage is actually this planet
uniting against the Federation and that
these slides are labeling weak points
for the next attack I had to go to the
CNC personally to get myself read into
what you people did on Discovery going
to any effort whatsoever trying to
figure out what the hell happened on
Discovery Samuel Kirk even though we're
old friends I'll say your first name
just in case anyone listening nearby
thought I might be talking about a
different Kirk one factor two skip it
I'm commandeering this airboat
phone's ringing again
here's their last transmission we
haven't heard from her since
you naked oh my God I am naked come on
in I've been assigned as acting first
officer
use it to be the man you most
essentially are it is that spot Captain
I'm the captain now I make minor
alterations to your genetic code
and induce internal Celerity to express
short-term changes to your biology is it
safe yes it's safe it's very safe so say
if you wouldn't believe it energized
I had to go to the CNC personally to get
myself reading to what you people did on
Discovery what do you mean you people
even in space
growth
sometimes
life uh
finds a way